die Engel Ben Kekse der Himmel rosaot es
ist die uns Verw hat und mit leckerin
belohnt es ist das Herz das ihr lacht es
wird aus Liebe gemacht so ein lieblicher
Duft in der
[Musik]
Luft hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
tortenwelt bei mir gibt's heute etwas
kalorienbewusstes und zwar möchte ich
heute ein kalorienbewusstes desser
machen und ihr kennt mich ja schon und
ihr wisst dass bei mir in der Küche
eigentlich nichts Kalorien beewusst ist
aber heute habe ich mir was einfahen
lassen wir machen heute leckere
schokoladencrebs mit einer
joghurtfüllung und Orangen und ich zeige
euch jetzt einfach mal ganz schnell die
Zutaten wir brauchen dafür 100 g Mehl 25
g Kakaopulver ein Ei
100 ml Milch 100 ml Mineralwasser eine
Pre Salz hier habe ich noch etwas
Vanilleextrakt ihr könnt auch
Vanilleschote oder Vanillezucker nehmen
und ich benutze noch etwa einen
Esslöffel Zucker wobei ihr den Zucker
auch weglassen könnt dann habt ihr da
einfach gar keinen Zucker drin und nehmt
dann einfach etwas Zucker später in der
Soße ich starte jetzt direkt mit dem
Teig und gebe jetzt dafür das Mehl in
meine Schüssel ich brauche dafür jetzt
auch gar keine küchenm
geht jetzt alles mit einem Schneebesen
da kommt Kakaopulver mit rein dann das
Ei eine Prise Salz nicht so viel denn
das wird ja ein süßer creb dann der
Zucker wer möchte kann auch statt Zucker
z.B Stevia benutzen das ist ja eine süße
ohne
Kalorien dann das
Vanilleextrakt und die
Milch und jetzt wird es erstmal ganz
kurz verrührt bevor ich jetzt die Milch
mit dazu gebe das Wasser mit dazu
gebe einfach damit die Klümpchen vom
Mehl und vom Kakaopulver
wegkommen und jetzt gebe ich da noch das
Wasser mit
rein und das ist jetzt so ein richtig
einfaches Dessert was man auch gut
vorbereiten kann denn den Teig lassen
wir jetzt gleich etwa eine halbe Stunde
stehen aber ihr könnt den z.B auch schon
mittags zubereiten und abends dann die
creb einfach nur noch ausbacken und
deswegen eignet sich das einfach super
z.B auch als Wein nachtsdessert oder
einfach mal so wenn sich Besuch
ankündigt und ihr habt einfach nicht so
viel
Zeit den Teig decke ich jetzt einfach
kurz ab und lass ihn an der Seite stehen
und in der Zeit bereite ich schon mal
meine Füllung
vor für die Füllung habe ich mir
überlegt dass ich einfach eine Joghurt
Quarkcreme mache weil man da ja einfach
fettreduzierte Produkte benutzen kann
z.B magaren Joghurt und mageren Quark
und ich zeige euch jetzt mal wie viel
ich davon benutze ich habe jetzt hier
125 g Quark 125 g Joghurt hier habe ich
zwei Esslöffel Zucker könnt ihr
natürlich wieder austauschen durch
Stevia oder noch weniger benutzen ich
habe hier zwei Bio Orangen und wieder
das
Vanilleextrakt und das erste was ich
jetzt mache ich habe die biooren bereits
gewaschen das sind natürlich jetzt
bioorangen damit ich einfach die Schale
mit verzerren kann und die reibe ich
jetzt einfach mal kurz
ab ich habe jetzt beide Orangenschalen
genommen und nehme jetzt einfach die
Hälfte davon die Hälfte gebe ich nämlich
in die Creme und die Hälfte davon in die
Orangencreme deswegen nehme ich mir
jetzt da ein bisschen davon zur Seite
und leg das kurz
weg und kümmer mich jetzt erstmal um die
Orangen die muss ich jetzt nämlich
erstmal filtieren und zwar schneide ich
da einfach unten hier den Deckel ab dann
oben
auch jetzt schneide ich hier am Rand
entlang dass die Schale praktisch
wegkommt und jetzt gehe ich direkt über
einen Topf mit der Orange damit ich
einfach den Saft auffangen kann und geht
ihr hier immer einmal mit dem Messer
rein das müsst ihr jetzt natürlich ganz
vorsichtig machen dass ihr euch nicht
schneidet und hol da immer diese
Orangenstücke
raus und dann bleibt da immer diese Haut
zwischendurch drin stehen und dann
geht's einfach weiter und dann drücke
ich den restlichen Saft einfach hier
noch mit in den rein da muss man den
eben nicht verschwenden und jetzt gebe
ich die Orangen hier auf den Herd geb da
jetzt noch die Orangenschale mit rein
die
Hälfte so haben wir ein richtig schönes
orangiges
Aroma und dann schalte ich jetzt mal den
Herd ein lass das Ganze kurz aufkochen
mit einem Esslöffel
Zucker kann so ein bisschen
einkochen und wer möchte nimmt sich
einfach ein paar Minzblätter und GI die
noch mit dazu dann haben wir hier noch
ein schönes minziges Aroma mit
drin ihr könnt aber auch z.B mit Nelken
oder zimtwürzen dass einfach bisschen
mehr Geschmack
reinkommt und das reicht jetzt auch
schon ich schalte das jetzt hier wieder
ab so und lass es jetzt einfach hier
kurz
abkühlen und in der Zeit kann ich jetzt
schon mal die Quarkcreme
machen neh ich einfach den gleichen
Löffel und gebt den Quark und den
Joghurt hier in die Schüssel rein
einfach zu den
Orangenschalen da kommt noch bisschen
Zucker mit dazu und etwas
Vanilleextrakt da braucht man auch nur
ganz wenig und das verrühre ich jetzt
noch mal kurz mit einem
Schneebesen und das könnt ihr jetzt auch
individuell abschmecken und einfach noch
andere Gewürze gerne mit dazu geben aber
ich finde es so schon richtig
lecker so dann kann ich das wieder kurz
an die Seite stellen die Orangen sind
auch bereit und jetzt kann ich bereits
meine Krebs ausbacken ich nehme jetzt
hier eine Pfanne die ist jetzt
beschichtet und erhitzt die jetzt
einfach mal und gebt ein bisschen
backtrennpray rein da habe ich einfach
den Vorteil ich braucht nicht viel Fett
ihr könnt es auch komplett ohne fett
machen aber da kann man es einfach so
ein bisschen damit
benetzen und sobald die Pfanne gleich
heiß ist gieße ich da gleich den
krenzteig rein
und wenn ihr jetzt merkt dass der Teig
noch ein bisschen zu dick ist Kön noch
ein bisschen Wasser mit dazu geben
dadurch werden die kräse nämlich richtig
schön dünn und man kann sie eben ganz
dün ausen so PNE ist jetzt heiß und der
Teig reicht für etwa a
Portionen gebe ich hier in die
Mitte und Schwenk die Pfanne herum dann
kann sich der Teig schön
verteilen dann warte ich kurz bis er an
der Oberfläche fest wird und kann ih
einmal
umhen und so backe ich jetzt all meine
acht porionen aus und dann können wir
sie gleich gefüllen ich habe jetzt meine
Krebs bereits ausgebacken wer möchte
kann jetzt diesen diese orange noch ein
bisschen Abbinden mit etwas Stärke ich
habe jetzt hier ein halben teöffel
Stärke geb den jetzt hiermit dazu weil
dann der Saft einfach gebunden wird und
ich kann das später dann schön eben über
diese Creme auch geben ohne dass es zu
sehr näst es reicht auch schon wenn es
einmal aufgekocht ist
und im Prinzip bin ich jetzt schon
fertig richtte mir hier mein Geschirr
und dann können wir es dekorieren so
jetzt geht's ans dekorieren das ist
jetzt natürlich ganz besonders wichtig
vor allem wenn wir im Teig und in der
Creme schon wenig Kalorien haben muss es
wenigstens schön aussehen und jetzt gebe
ich einfach ein bisschen von der Creme
hier auf den KB drauf aber nur etwa auf
die Hälfte denn ich will es gleich
zusammenrollen und möchte nicht dass es
irgendwo am Rand rausquillt dann kommt
da ein bisschen von der orangenmasse mit
drauf
das passt natürlich perfekt zu der
Schokolade und macht das Ganze so
richtig
fruchtig und jetzt wird es zusammeng
gerollt ich klapp das jetzt hier oben
einmal ein und Roll das ganze dann
einmal
zusammen und so sieht es ja noch nicht
so hübsch aus also nehme ich mir ein
Messer und teile das einmal
durch hab praktisch so zwei ft und nehme
jetzt einen frischen Teller und servier
das ganze jetzt da
drauf hier habe ich noch mal so ein paar
Orangen
Filets dann noch etwas
pepperminze bisschen abreg von der
Zitronenschale und wer möchte kann noch
ein bisschen Puderzucker nehmen das
müsste aber nicht dann könnt ihr euch
hier die Kalorien natürlich auch noch
sparen und so sieht dann mein fertiges
kalorienbewusstes Dessert aus für
Weihnachten und dieses Rezept gibt's zum
Nachlesen auf
sellis-blog.de ich freue mich wenn ihr
das nächste Mal auch wieder dabei seid
da gibt's auch wieder eine leckere
Köstlichkeit und ich wünsche euch allen
noch einen ganz schönen Tag bis zum
nächsten Mal
[Musik]
tschüss
übrigens findet ihr alle Produkte die
ich heute benutzt habe auch bei mir im
Shop auf sellis-shop.de und ich wünsche
euch jetzt allen noch eine richtig
schöne besinnliche Weihnachtszeit
genießt die Zeit mit euren Freunden mit
eurer Familie bis bald tschüss
tschüss